c'est l'heure du repas chez la famille
bois et on sort les boîtes à lunch même
si les enfants ne sont pas à l'école
une façon de ne pas trop perturber le
train-train quotidien même en journée de
grève c'est quand même une répétition de
ce qu'on a eu pendant deux ans c'est bon
c'est ça les enfants font de
l'apprentissage virtuel pendant que les
parents télétravail maintiennent à
laquelle la famille s'était habituée
pendant la pandémie tout en espérant ne
plus avoir à y revenir qui vont perdre
des jours scolaires des jours scolaires
qui sont précieux parce qu'on en a perdu
énormément
depuis des semaines c'est l'impasse
entre le gouvernement food et les
employés de soutien dans les écoles aide
enseignant concierge bibliothécaire tous
ont débrayés pour obtenir de meilleurs
salaires on est responsable pour les
enfants qui sont la future de le pays
que tout le monde pourquoi
les travailleurs accusent le
gouvernement de les avoir intimidés en
adoptant une loi spéciale qui leur a
imposé un contrat et empêcher de
débrayer les grévistes s'exposent à une
amende maximale de 4000 dollars par jour
et
à 500000 dollars de pénalité par jour
ces travailleurs en ont assis ils sont
désespérés Martel cette représentante
syndicale
le gouvernement Ford lui maintient la
ligne dure une posture intransigeante
plus le Premier ministre Justin Trudeau
a dénoncé préoccupé par le recours à la
disposition de dérogation la Charte
canadienne des droits et libertés qui
nous protège tous
est essentiel
et ne doit pas être contourné là on va
nulle part Emmanuel non plus ne voit pas
d'un bon œil le recours à une loi
spéciale mais il ne soutient pas
forcément les grévistes on prend les
élèves en otage on prend les parents en
otage pour l'instant son épouse et lui
peuvent télétravailler sans problème et
parviennent même à profiter de cette
journée en famille mais Emmanuel
s'inquiète surtout pour la suite des
choses c'est vendredi donc la fin de
semaine c'est dans quelques heures ce
sera surtout la semaine prochaine qu'on
va voir ce que comment ça va se passer
le syndicat a promis de débrayer aussi
longtemps que nécessaire peu importe les
coûts ou les conséquences le
gouvernement ne semble pas non plus
avoir l'intention de reculer
Radio-Canada Toronto